je vais vous dire j'ai eu un chroniqueur
ou une chroniqueuse au téléphone ce
matin ah et on a déduit qu'on pouvait
faire l'émission à 4 voir 5
je peux pas dire ça ce matin mais j'ai
eu quelqu'un au téléphone
une fois un chroniqueur ou une chronique
que je n'irai pas sur une femme
avec lesquels vous discutez de la
manière dont fonctionne l'émission oui
mais une proximité qui regrettable pour
le reste de l'équipe
dans les quatre forcément ah oui et on a
déduit qu'on a déduits
avec cette chronique cœur
c'est Guillaume il est producteur aussi
il doit faire des économies
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lumineux
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dû insister
on vous parlera de cette discussion
parce que ça vous concerne également
qui sont les quatre forcément
après après 10 minutes de conversation
on a rectifié on a dit peut-être pour
faire les missions à 6
avec Guigui il faut Guigui
Daniel on a alors toi on n'a pas pris
des risques on s'est dit on sait pas
elle tant qu'elle est là on en profite
tu sais c'est le secteur mais c'est vrai
c'est comme tu veux avoir de la famille
à très loin ta vieille tante tu sais
jamais si c'est la dernière fois
le risque voilà j'ai une petite remarque
en fait vous avez fait le tour le seul
dont vous n'avez pas parlé c'est
Castaldi
je vais vous dire
je sais ce que Valérie a dit quelque
chose qui était vrai ce matin alors
Valérie j'ai dit que Benjamin était
essentiel parce que c'était très bon
censé là sa famille il a beaucoup
d'enfants
[Applaudissements]
pour moi la famille
chez lui non mais c'est vrai il a un
enfant par an ça commence à faire
beaucoup on a adoré Benji
la vérité est-ce qu'il fait partie des
quatre
[Applaudissements]